[موسيقى]
اذا الغيم تنهمر الحروف
لها نغم يحس به الشغوف
يرى فيها غصونا باسقات
على اطرافها تدنو القطوف
[موسيقى]
فان لبثت مقاليد المعاني مسطره تنوء بها
الرفوف
فتحنا في صميم العلم بابابا فقال الدهر قد
جاز الوقوف
[موسيقى]
قال ابو اسحاق الشيرازي سهرت مع ابي ذات
ليله نقوم الليل وحولنا قوم النيام فقلت
لابي لم يقم من هؤلاء من يصلي ركعتين فقال
يا بني لو نمت لكان خيرا لك من الوقوع في
الخلق
تذكر ان طاعتك لا ينبغي لها ان تسمح لك
بالسخريه من معصيه الاخرين وتذكر ان نبي
الله سليمان عليه السلام
وقف لنمله
ولست بسليمان
وليس الخلق نمله السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]
قد نستعمل المفرد مع المثنى في اللغه
العربيه فنقول رايت الرجلين نفسهما بدل
نفسيهما وقد نستعمل الجمع فنقول رايت
الرجلين انفسهما ومن استعمل المثنى مع
المثنى فقال رايت الرجلين نفسيهما فلا حرج
عليه
وجاء في القران الكريم في سوره الكهف فلما
بلغا مجمع بينهما نسيا حوتهما والذي نسي
واحد منهما فقط وقال المفسرون ان سنن
العرب جرت على مخاطبه الاثنين كقول الشاعر
قفا نبكي وجاء في الذكر الحكيم والسارق
والسارقه فاقطعوا ايدياهما والقطع يكون
لليمنين بالمثنى لا للايدي كلها وانما
وردت بالجمع لغرض التوكيد ومن ذلك الايه
ان تتوب الى الله فقد صغت قلوبكما والمراد
قلباكما وجاء بصيغه الجمع كما قال ابن
عاشور لثقل توالي صيغه المثنى
ولما كان القران الكريم الاساس والمرجع في
اللغه العربيه فانه يعلمنا ان قلب اللغه
يتسع للتساهل في امر المثنى والمفرد
والجمع للايفاء بغايات بلاغيه كالتوكيد
وتجنب الثقل هذا مع شرط مهم ان يكون
المعنى واضحا جليا من خلال السياق ويعرف
كل من عمل في مهنه الاعلام الصعوبه التي
يلقاها عندما يجتمع عليه المثنى مضاعفا
كان يصاب شخصان اثنان في حادثين متشابهين
لكن في منطقتين متباعدتين فتاتي العباره
مثلا على النحو التالي وكان كلاهما قد
اصيبا في منطقتيهما اللتين كانتا في اطراف
المدينه وكان يجتازاني حاجزين للشرطه
وعليهما لافتتان بان المرور ممنوع ولكنهما
لم يلتفتا الى اللافتتين
المسمى مما اختصت به اللغه العربيه في حين
اسقطته بعض اخواتها من اللغات الساميه وهو
في صلب العربيه وفي كثير من الاحيان
لافكاك منه والتسهيل مطلوب في كل حال
[موسيقى]
قال معاويه لصحار بن عياش العبدي ما هذه
البلاغه التي فيكم يا عبد القيس قال شيء
يختلج في صدورنا
فتقذفه السنتنا كما يقذف البحر الزبد قال
فما البلاغه عندكم قال ان تقول فلا تخطئ
وتجيب فلا تبطئ
وقال ابن المقفع البلاغه اجاعه اللفظ
واشباع المعنى وعن البلاغه ايضا قال
الخليل بن احمد البلاغه ما قرب طرفاه وبعد
منتهى
ويقول ابن رشيق الايجاز ذروه سنام البلاغه
جاء في البيان والتبيين انه قيل للفارسي
ما البلاغه قال معرفه الوصل من الفصل وقيل
لليوناني ما البلاغه فقال تصحيح الاقسام
واختيار الكلام وقيل للرومي ما البلاغه
فقال حسن الاقتضاض عند البداهه والغزاره
يوم الاطاله وقيل للهندي ما البلاغه فقال
وضوح الدلاله وانتهاز الفرصه وحسن الاشاره
[موسيقى]
قال الاصمعي اختصم اعرابيان الى احد
الولاه في دين لاحدهما على صاحبه فجعل
المدعى عليه يحلف بالطلاق والعتاق فقال له
المدعي دعني من هذه الايمان واحلف بما
اقول لك لا ترك الله لك خفا يتبع خفا ولا
ظلفا يتبع ظلفا وحتى من اهلك ومالك حتى
الورق من الشجر ان لم يكن لي هذا الحق من
قبلك
فاعطاه حقه ولم يحلف له
وقيل يمين لا يحلف بها اعرابي ابدا لا
اورد الله لك صادره ولا اصدر لك وارده ولا
حطت رحلك ولا وضعت نعلك
[موسيقى]
تقول للعرب في امثالها انما هو كبرق الخلب
فما معنى هذا المثل
برق خلب وبرق خلب بالاضافه هو البرق الذي
لا غيث معه كانه خادع يغمض حتى تطمع بمطره
ثم يخلف ويقال سحاب خلب اي سحاب خادع غير
ممطر ويضرب هذا المثل لمن يعد ثم يخلف ولا
ينجز
يقول الشاعر وعدت وكان الخلف منك سجيه
مواعيد عرقوب اخاه بيثرب ويقول كثير عزه
كاني واياها سحابه ممحل رجاها فلما جاوزته
استهلتي
[موسيقى]
سالتكم في تويتر عن اخر كلمه عربيه
تعلمتموها وقلت لكم انني قرات كلمه مسعنجر
في قصيده لابي تمام ثم هرعت الى المعجم
ابحث عن معناها
فيما استعرض معكم بعض الكلمات الجديده
التي تعلمتموها وبعد ذلك اخبركم بمعنى
كلمه مسعنجر
هذه مشاركه من مايكروسوفت وورد شخصيا يقول
ان الكلمه التي تعلمها هي كلمه ممدوحه
والممدوح في اللغه تعني السعه قل انت في
ممدوحه من امرك يعني انت في ساعه من امرك
مشاركه من اناث تقول مدهش هو معجم ابي
تمام وابن الرومي
ويوظفون الكلمات الغريبه توظيفا حسنا لا
يشعرك بغرابتها يقول ابو تمام نفسي فداءك
اي باب ملمه لم يرم فيه اليك بالاقليل
الله ويقول ابن الرومي مثلا
لكنهم كالمسك طاب لعينه ويزيد حين يخاطب
المجداح
مشاركه من سلمى بدري تقول فهل من مدكر
تشير الى كلمه مدكر في سوره القمر
وهناك بيت جاهلي قديم يقول
ذكرت بها الاجابه ومن يسافر كما سافرت
يدكر الاجابه
هذا فيما يتعلق بالابتكار وهو بمعنى
التذكر على كل حال
[موسيقى]
الم او اكسترا اوثر يقول الاكتشاك في
قصيده المتنبي الاكتشاك معناه الكذب يقول
المتنبي وما ارضى لمقلته بحلم اذا انتبهت
توهمه ابتشاك هذه طبعا من القصيده الشهيره
التي يقول فيها المتنبي في مطلعها فدا لك
من يقصر عن مداك فما ملك اذا الا فداك
مشاركه ايضا من محمد منصور يقول
يقفون ينتظرون خلف ظهورنا حتى نميل بعارض
متعنجر
يقول قول ابن عباس وقد ذكر علي رضي الله
تعالى عنهما علمي الى علمه كالقراره في
المثعنجر اي مقيسا الى علمه كالقراره
موضوعه في جنب المسنجر المثعنجر توقع حان
الوقت ان نقول ما هي هي السيل الكبير
عندما تمطر الدنيا مطرا غزيرا
فيقولون
يعني هذا مطرا وابله مسعنجر واي
تسيل منه السيول
مازال هناك مشاركات هذه المشاركه من نوال
تقول الخنزير وهو الشاعر المميز
والمنقح تقول قد لا تكون هي اخر كلمه
تعلمتها من اللغه العربيه ولكنها الاكثر
رسوخا واستقرارا
الدكتور محمد شحاته
استحضر ابيات من الشعر كلها ورد فيها نفس
اللفظ التي اوردتها لكم فقال البيت الذي
وقعت عليه لشار ابي تمام وهو قوله كم ليله
اسى البلاد بنفسه فيها ويوم وابله متعنجر
وفي بيت اخر يقول متعنجر كف المظفر افقه
لم يبقى ذا عدم ولا مسؤوده
[موسيقى]
يقول ايضا والروض لست تراه ابل جناظرا الا
بحيث ترى الحياه مثعنجر
ومشاركه لابني معد يقول ارتاشا قصيده
قراتها في احدى قصص ميخائيل نعيمه منذ
يومين واستوقفتني ومعناها بالعاميه اغتنى
يقولون ارتاش بمعنى اغتنى
اقف معكم اذا عند هذه
المشاركه اشكر لكم هذه الكلمات الجديده
التي تعلمناها معا واذكركم دائما بان
تبحث في المعاجم عن الكلمات التي
لا تعرفون معناها ليس عيبا ان نعود الى
المعجم بين الحين والحين
وجميل ان تشاركوا معنا دائما وتضع اسم
تاملات الجزيره
[موسيقى]
عن شاعر اليمن احدثكم البردوني
في سبعينيات القرن العشرين صبغت الرمزيه
على الطريقه الاوروبيه الشعر العربي
تاثر السياب ونازك الملائكه بما درساه في
الجامعه من الشعر الانجليزي
وتنبهها الى اتكاء شعراء الانجليز على
الهه الاغريق وعلى قصص الالياذه وكل خرافه
قديمه فكان في طليعه من بدا هذا التيار
لما لا يفعل الشاعر العربي مثل هذا وعنده
تاريخ عريض مليء بالخرافات الممتعه
ثم اخذ الشعراء يستعملون اللغه استعمالات
ملتويه بغرض الايحاء وليس فقط بغرض ايصال
المعنى وليكن المعنى غامضا وليكن غير
مفهوم ما فتات السرياليه الادبيه تلفح
شعرنا بين الحين والحين
ولم يسلم من ذلك شاعر اليمن
البردوني رغم بعده عن مركز التاثر بالشعر
الاجنبي وعدم المهامه بالشعر الاوروبي
ورغم التزامه بعمود الشعر لكنه ركب الموجه
قال البردوني يصف جريحا
لا تلمه اذا شكى ان شكواه واناته دخان
اتقاده
كلما قال اه هي اوصاع عدد الانفاس شاهدت
قطعه من فؤاده
[موسيقى]
وليس في هذا شيء من الرمز
نؤجل ذلك قليلا وقال البردوني يصف يمنيا
مشردا
عرفته يمنيا في تلفته خوف وعيناه تاريخ من
الرمد من خضره القات في عينيه اسئله صفرا
تبوح كعودا النصف متقدي رايت فيه كبيلادي
كلها اجتمعت
كيف التقت تسعه المليون في جسدي
[موسيقى]
وفي هاتين القطعتين تاثرا لا يخفى ببيتين
للاخطل الصغير يصف مسلولا
يقول عيناه عالقتان في نفق كسراج كوخ نصف
متقدي ويمج احيانا دما فعلى من ديله قطعا
من الكبد
وللبردوني صوره قلميه بديعه في وصف انفجار
هذه الصوره التي رسمها لسان الشاعر الكفيف
ابلغ تاثيرا من صوره فيديو متحركه اصحابها
صوت هادر قال البردوني
اقبلت كل هدكاكين والهاء
كبغايه هربنا من نسف ملهى
لم يعد من يجي وجاءت سقوف فوق اخرى
واه اتى فوق اوهى
كان يستفسر الغبار الشظايا
المرايا او الجراحات ازهى اقبلت كلها
العمارات عجلا
تمتطي مخبزا
وتجتر مقهى
[موسيقى]
الان الان هذه نفحه من رمزيه البردوني
اسمع
هذه الحجاج كانثى ما لها رحم هذا الزحام
رجال ما به رجل
غاصت وجوه الروابي تحت ارجلها في جلد كل
حصاه ينطوي جبل وكان يهمس من خلف الهدير
فم لا يوريق الناس حتى تذبل الدول
اذا اعجبتك فهذه واحده اخرى
ماذا يسر لسفح الربوه الحجر
كان كل حصاه هاهنا خبر
لكل واحده شكل وتمتمه لكن يوحدهن العجز
والضجر
في شهر البردوني نرى ارياف اليمن التي ظلت
غافيه زمنا بين الجبال نرى عهد الائمه
والعهد الجمهوري نرى الفرقه والوحده في
شعره نعيش حياه اليمن في ذلك الزمن
الشعر العربي في القرن العشرين حتى وهو
يداعب الرمزيه كما في شعر البردوني يمثل
مراه ثقيله للمجتمع
ولحركه التاريخ ليس فيه تواريخ بالسنوات
والاشهر لكن فيه صوره المراحل التي مر بها
كل شعب
وانتهى القرن العشرون ثم كان الشعر العربي
فقد ايمانه بالتحولات السياسيه وفقد
اهتمامه بالمجتمع واصبح مراه يرى نفسه
فيها فقط ضل الشعر ديوان العرب الفا
وخمسمائه سنه واول امس لم يعد كذلك
وكان يهمس من خلف الهدير فم لا يغرق الناس
حتى تذبل الدول
[موسيقى]
الناس اغراض الزمان وانما يتفاضل الاخيار
في زمن الغير والشعر تاريخ نسير بظله ما
نحن من دون الشوارد والعبر
السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]